[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
did Trump endorse
Brazilian Nazis
of course he did why wouldn't he
Brazilian Nazis
must be
must be a pattern
a pattern that we will see
on Tuesday
here's what I mean there's a video going
around of the
Brazilian Nazis who lost a Brazilian
fastest who lost the election they
showed up at a military installment
and started singing the National Anthem
with the Nazi salute towards the
installment
demanding that they win the election
or I don't know storm the capital spread
[ __ ] all over the walls overturn the
government I don't it sounds familiar to
me
sounds familiar does it sound familiar
to you there's a lot of news a lot of
news uh dropping today uh in late
yesterday after the show
so we have to get to that cash Patel is
now now in a limited use immunity deal
with the doj and the FBI and the
cultists have no clue they didn't they
don't know this he's going on oan
Newsmax Fox News some kind of Trader
News Network I don't know he's all over
Trader news networks talking about how
they should defund and eliminate the FBI
and doj as he makes a deal to save his
ass
look
limited use Immunity on this documents
case
for his testimony
is a big deal
cash Patel and his attorneys would not
be looking for limited limited use
immunity
if he did not commit crimes and the doj
does not have evidence of it now I don't
know what it is I mean you could imagine
all kinds of things
that surround the Cheeto dusk Cuban
honor stealing our classified documents
for many different imaginary reasons you
could think of right like there's a lot
of things you could come up with of why
he stole these documents number one they
had his name on him
they are about him these classified
documents are about him he would steal
them to use them as blackmail so that
he's not indicted he would also use them
to probably sell or trade for [ __ ]
you can imagine all sorts of different
things we don't know yet
I bet cash Patel does
Raul
I bet he knows
I bet doj knows some [ __ ] that he knows
probably
the other thing cash Patel probably
knows is where the rest of these [ __ ]
documents are
hmm
Maybe
seems like that's why they would Grant
him limited use immunity
I don't know if you know this or not
federal government does not issue
limited use immunity
they just don't do it that often it is
very [ __ ] rare
in any case
now 98 of all federal cases
end up in plea deals almost every single
one of them
and the reason why is because the
federal government has nothing but time
and money
and a whole line of new prosecutors
it's not like in some states where one
prosecutor goes away and the next one
comes up and and they just decide that's
case is not good for them
it doesn't exactly happen like that in
the United States attorney's office
not exactly
so cash Patel being granted limited use
immunity folks is a sign that Merrick
Garland is targeting someone
the doj is targeting someone in a
criminal investigation
surrounding the documents that were
found at Mar-A-Lago
in Donald Trump's safe in his death
drawer on his floor and in melania's
closet okay
it isn't hard to see what's happening
here
it is not that difficult and they are
freaking the [ __ ] out
freaking the [ __ ] out
Donald Trump chewing Tiss James in
Florida even that's how desperate they
are they they know this is all going to
come tumbling down
not only is his is his business his
[ __ ] business that he ran for decades
now in criminal trial
undergoing criminal trial as we speak
tis James is walking that business same
business to Civil Trial and he's trying
to sue her in Florida okay
it's not supposed to make sense
it's not supposed to none of this none
of this is supposed to make sense at all
I mean really honestly if you if you
think that this is supposed to make
sense then you're not doing you're not
doing life correctly
you're just not doing like correctly if
you think this is supposed to make sense
limited use immunity
have you have you been watching people
say the doj needs to do something they
need to do something
the federal government Merrick Garland
they need to lock him away
folks
there is no clearer sign
that the doj sees Donald Trump as a
Target now we can talk about the state
elector scheme in January 6.
and we can talk about some of these
other cases like in Georgia the again
the criminal case of this ongoing your
hey manga your orange Mussolini Jesus is
under criminal trial right now in the
state of New York and he's freaking out
because of it he's filing lawsuits in
Florida which makes no sense against the
New York attorney general
he's trying to open up businesses in New
Jersey to move his assets because he's
[ __ ] he's completely [ __ ] the other
thing we find out more more news on the
Cheeto desk you in honor he has to
settle out of court
with the people that his bodyguards
roughed up the protesters outside Trump
Tower because he can't go to trial on
that
he can't let people know that he ordered
his security to go rough protesters up
so he settles that Accord he does this
every time
he's not going to be able to settle out
of court in the criminal case he will
not be able to settle out of court for
the documents case
they're not civil cases
and I I highly doubt now that he's suing
this James if she is going to the
attorney general that stayed in New York
is going to just settle out of court
with that civil case against the Trump
organization
which I believe that tits James is going
to cut down the Trump organization like
a fresh cut tree
all the way to the [ __ ] ground
that's what they're terrified of their
money laundering machine is about to dry
up the only thing they got left
is their grift in their Maga world
and that might dry up after this
election I don't know if you've noticed
but the media and the polls were [ __ ]
wrong
I've been telling you they're wrong for
a long time they're way off
this country this country is sick and
tired of their nonsense their [ __ ]
we do not want Maga fascists here
anymore
it is not a thing that we want we we are
sick of you talking about your nonsense
shut the [ __ ] sit down shut the [ __ ] up
okay got it
we're gonna do the whole American thing
Libertarians is trending on Twitter this
morning oh this is hilarious
Libertarians
again I've always said that that
conservatives no one's ever they're not
[ __ ] conservative they've always thin
veiled their fascism as conservatism
with taxes and
national debt and all that [ __ ] you
know the Tea Party Movement taxed enough
already that's all thin male fascism
as conservatism what do you think
libertarianism is it's [ __ ] thin
veiled fascism
I mean here's literally if you've ever
talked to someone who claims to be a
Libertarian I'm a Libertarian I believe
the government didn't give me this
government bad government bad this
government we are the government you
[ __ ] [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
we the people that's the whole [ __ ]
point of the democratic constitutional
republic in the first place
[ __ ] boneheads here's the libertarian
idea oh I want to get rid of government
so elect me to the government you are a
dumb [ __ ] that's literally how
every every one of these libertarian
politicians that's how their speech
starts
I want to get rid of the government so
elect me to the government
really stupid [ __ ] so what you're saying
there what you're saying they're cheap
is you gotta govern
or it's really [ __ ] dumb
that in 2022 there's people out there
that don't realize that you have to I
don't know set policy and govern things
the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] are you people
talking about
even an ancient Rome they knew these
kind of things that you had to govern
set policy
really [ __ ] stupid
but what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do they've tried to Rebrand and
Rebrand and Rebrand their fascism
over and over and over again in the last
30 years
and folks this idea that there's a
majority of people in this country who
believe this Maga [ __ ] that is such
a crock of [ __ ] [ __ ] it is a crock of
[ __ ] we are not divided that's not a
thing I know you I know there's a lot of
[ __ ] vitriol there's a lot of it
seems like there's a lot of [ __ ]
trolls out there
but literally you know you know the
Mystic terrorist group the three
percenters do you know why they call
themselves The Three percenters because
they believe it only takes three percent
of the population to overturn the
[ __ ] government
they [ __ ] believe that it's why they
call themselves The Three percenters
and that's probably not even close to
how many they have three percent
like the group called themselves the
three presenters they are not even close
to having three percent of the
population in their [ __ ] group in the
first place
I'll give an example this [ __ ] Maga
this Maga Hammer assassin at the
Pelosi's house
[ __ ] q and honor through and
through I mean bone deep Q Anon with
this son of a [ __ ] delusional as [ __ ]
he's even gonna use this as his defense
that's what he's gonna use he's [ __ ]
deluded he's a he's been brainwashed
he's been mind [ __ ] by cubanon that's
why he did this he's crazy I mean you
know I know maybe it's a decent defense
but here's the thing
as soon as this guy shows up
and bashes Paul Pelosi's head in with a
hammer
he's a Democrat all of a sudden
he's gay
dude was dude was disseminating
information that was coming directly
from Tucker Carlson's [ __ ] mouth
Matt Walsh's [ __ ] mouth Ben Shapiro's
[ __ ] mouth
Laura Ingram's [ __ ] mouth Steve
bannon's [ __ ] mouth he was
disseminating this information Trump's
truth social feed
it's not hard to figure out folks
it's not hard to figure out and you know
what they did you know what they did
online to this [ __ ] rightfully
so I guess
he's a Democrat he's a liberal he's a
nudist he's a socialist like they turn
on him immediately
no questions they turned on that
[ __ ] they turned on the Maga
Hammer assassin he thought he was going
to be a [ __ ] hero he was going to go
assassinate Nancy Pelosi their [ __ ]
online wet dream
Jesus Christ there were hundreds of them
that marched up to the Capitol after the
Cheeto dusk q and honor told him to go
there they were gonna kill Nancy Pelosi
and hang Mike Pence his [ __ ] vice
president
this guy should be a [ __ ] hero to
them but he's not
they should be like yeah we want that
he's one of us
it's because there's not that many of
them folks that's the [ __ ] fraud
that's the [ __ ] fraud that's been
wrought on us for [ __ ] years now is
that there's a gazillions there's
gazillions of trump supporters out 75
percent of the country lose Donald Trump
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
listen I agree with Carrie Lake when she
says 81 million people didn't vote for
Joe Biden because a shitload a [ __ ]
shitload of those 81 million people
voted against people like Carrie Lake
voted against trumpism voted against
fascism they don't want it just like in
Brazil they told them to [ __ ] off
and in Brazil the Nazis show up with the
Nazi salute
with their national flag
giving the Hitler the Heil Hitler
hand salute while they're singing the
National Anthem because they lost and
they don't want to lose it sounds
familiar
of course it seems like Brazil is going
to uh try to have a peaceful transfer of
power
but the sickness is Broad and wide and
it's not just here
but we have to take care of our own
house now we are just days away days
away folks from the most important
election of our democracy's lifetime
and I've I've said it a hundred times
and I'll say it 100 more if I have to by
Tuesday
as soon as the votes are in as soon as
they're counted and certified and
Democrats have won seats that you never
dreamed they would have won
because of you
because of the people
because of the exhausted majority
they're sick and tired of the fascism
they're sick and tired of the [ __ ]
the bigotry
they want to get down to business they
want to fix the problems that we do have
instead of worrying about [ __ ] that
doesn't no one [ __ ] cares about
that doesn't affect it doesn't affect
you it has nothing to do with you
they want to get down to business
they want to make sure that people have
decent [ __ ] Health Care they want to
make sure they have a decent [ __ ]
wage they want to make sure you don't go
broke going to [ __ ] college or
getting an education to get a [ __ ]
decent job
they want to make sure you can retire
decent that you're not going to get your
Social Security your [ __ ] Medicare
taken away from you it's not an
entitlement you [ __ ] we paid
for it
Mike Lee you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
people are sick and tired of these
[ __ ] telling us what the [ __ ]
we're gonna do
Americans are tired of it
they're sick of it
and I believe
next week on Tuesday it's gonna show
through I'm very [ __ ] confident I've
been confident for a long time these
naysayers out there now they're tucking
tail and running like oh what but these
these early voting numbers boy they
really uh we might have been wrong about
the the those polls uh it may have been
right Wingers
um trying to put those polls uh so that
the Aggregate and it maybe tricked the
media into into having a certain
narrative like the uh the fentanyl
Halloween candy have you watched any
news agency any news Network anywhere
they for months they talked about
fentanyl being in Halloween and Skittles
bags not one of them is is talking about
how that was all [ __ ] not [ __ ]
one of them
they should have it on the front pages
of their newspapers they should have it
on the front and the front first [ __ ]
hour of their goddamn shows on TV that
they apologize for spreading that
[ __ ]
that it was a bunch of nonsense it made
no sense it was a [ __ ] conspiracy
theory
and it had no basis in fact other than
other than a bunch of [ __ ] Republican
Nazis were disseminating it that's the
only fact is that they were
disseminating lies and the media was
believing it the same way these polls no
no one was handing out fentanyl at
Halloween no people are tired of
Republicans fascist [ __ ] they're
gonna go vote against them
they're not even going to go vote for
Democrats and you I I you can go vote
for a Democrat if you want but my my
suggestion is to go vote against fascism
that's what I would do I would go vote
pro-democracy and vote against the
people who want to destroy your
democracy vote against those
[ __ ]
people love to vote against [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah this idea this idea that
Democrats need to hold hands and Kumbaya
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's time to fight for your goddamn
democracy it's time to fight for your
goddamn principles it's time to stand up
tell them to [ __ ] off
[ __ ] you you don't get to you don't get
to tell us what we're gonna do and what
we're not gonna do you don't get to tell
us the government the people
that we have to hate someone because
they they identify or have a certain
pronoun you [ __ ] idiot you don't you
don't get to you don't get to convince
us that the main problem with education
is your obsession with children's
genitalia you [ __ ] weirdo we don't
have to put up with that bull [ __ ] we do
not have to do it we can vote against
that nonsense
and it's time now is the time to go vote
against that [ __ ]
go vote against that nonsense
I've heard this over and over oh well
the that's fear-mongering
I don't know if you watched a
documentary on what happened in the
1930s and 1940s but it's not fear folks
it's not fear it's it's history and
reality repeating itself
I have a good friend from Luxembourg I
was speaking to him yesterday
his grandfather
was near Germany in the 1930s and 1940s
as a kid
he would tell him how it happened
and he said look
if we don't turn this around now this is
exactly what my grandfather was telling
me
folks
it's time to stand against these
[ __ ]
it's time to stand for truth and against
lies
and the LIE the lie that they have big
support is the biggest [ __ ] lie
the why that they have big support in
this country that Fascism and these
ideas have big support in this country
is a bigger lie than the big lie that
[ __ ] Trump won in 2020. that's it's a
bigger [ __ ] lie they do not have the
support that they say they have it's all
[ __ ] it's all to scare you it's all
the scare people on the fence
because folks when fascism starts to
seep in it's either eat or be eaten what
do you think happened in Nazi Germany
you think you think people became Nazis
because they wanted to
human beings will do some damn some damn
crazy things to protect themselves and
their families they'll do some crazy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] they never dreamed they would do to
protect themselves and their families
and when fascism takes hold
of a country it's either eat or be eaten
and we cannot allow that to happen here
in this country
we have to head it off and cut the head
off of this snake now
and Now's the Time if you can vote early
go [ __ ] vote now if you've already
voted go find those three people that
you are going to encourage to vote that
is the weapon that we use to save our
way of life
they'll come for you they'll come for
your church they're going to come for
your children's School
they're gonna come for the PTA
they're going to come from the city
councils they're going to come they're
going to come for the goddamn dog
catchers
they're coming for you
if you don't make sure that this
election has the biggest turnout ever
and it is up to you
and the bare minimum is to use your
ballot to have your voice heard
that's the bare minimum
but I am asking you
to do your debt Democratic Duty and lean
in
to our Democratic constitutional
republic
and show these fascists Who We Are
I ask you find three people to encourage
and get those three people to encourage
three more and once you find them I mean
we're Thursday we got several days left
once you find them
find three more and don't stop
ask the real questions
ask the real questions it's really easy
say you're you say you're one of the
three people that you're going to talk
to I don't know what happens to
be on Social Security because they
earned it they paid for it out of every
[ __ ] paycheck that they have they
have Medicare too maybe ask them have
you seen the pic the video of Mike Lee
Lindsey Graham and other Republicans
United States senators who are gun are
saying that they want to take away
Social Security Medicare
the thing that I don't know make sure
you ain't gotta go work
that you can retire in your old age
not have to worry
they want to strip it away from me have
you seen the video of it
and then show them the [ __ ] video
that's a great place to start I don't
know if you got a younger younger folks
younger folks
you could say did you see that the
Republicans in this country absolutely
don't want affordable education because
they don't want you to have a decent
wage
did you see that where where's that all
the repo only Republican attorney
general sued to make sure that people
didn't get student debt relief from
their interest that they're paying on
their student loans because that's what
it is you ain't getting your [ __ ]
principal [ __ ] forgiven it's it's
[ __ ] interest on most these loans
it's the interest
start there ask them have you seen what
Rhonda Santos wants to do when he's
Banning Book Fairs
and blaming math on CRT
ask about bounty hunters
in Texas where they can have a ten
thousand dollar bounty on a woman's body
because they want to
ask them about Tennessee where they were
trying to pass a bill to marry children
ask them
ask the question
what about in Ohio
where JD Vance called Donald Trump
America's Hitler and then he raised
money
for Donald Trump
to take over and overthrow our vote in
our government on January 6th
ask him
um
might be an easy thing to do
it's time to lean in
it's time
I I know I've been saying it for many
many months now
we cannot we cannot
stop
we cannot stop talking we cannot stop
yelling we cannot stop having these
conversations
it is most important to our democracy
today right now in this moment
because we only have a few days left
to make sure we pile them under
mountains of votes and folks I'm very
confident
I'm very I you know this if you've been
listening if you've been in this
audience which you are the best audience
in the world if you've been in this
audience the last few months you know
that I've been saying
I believe the Democrats are going to
pile them under mountains of votes
the early voting numbers are showing
that
that we absolutely are going to pile
them
under mountains and mountains of [ __ ]
you votes not just a vote against him
but a big [ __ ] you
you do not get to take away women's
rights you not get to tell people what
they can and cannot identify as what
clothes they can wear you don't get to
[ __ ] be weird about children's
genitalia and what bathrooms are going
you don't get to do that [ __ ]
you don't this is America you don't get
to do that [ __ ] people have the Liberty
to have the freedom and rights
so engage in your democracy come here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central nine
Pacific we do two full hours we show you
how to engage we do not shy away from
making sure that sunlight is the best
disinfectant on these fascists we do it
every single weekday two full hours
that's why they try to get me to shut up
ah they're trying to shut me up big time
Big Time trying to get me to stop
talking won't do it it drives me even
harder
to talk more and to yell more I I want
to do I want to do 12 hours a day
when they're trying to shut me up
I won't stop doing this show it's not
gonna happen
and I'm not gonna apologize for doing
this show it's not gonna happen you can
[ __ ] off
and you should have the same attitude
about your democracy
you're going to do whatever it takes to
save your way of life
because this democracy is worth it it
might not be perfect
no democracy really is that's the point
kind of
is to work hard
at governing and setting policy and
progressing
and making sure we're getting better and
inching closer closer to more equality
and more equity for everybody no matter
who they are where they're from
rather they were born here what what's
the color of their skin what Creed
they're from what religion they are
rather they have religion or not
everyone in this country should have the
Liberty
so folks listen every single weekday and
stick around because we're going to go
through and I'm going to show you some
stuff to be showing those Maga family
members of yours they're like yeah I'm
on Social Security I paid for social
security for years I deserve it
they want to take it away I'm going to
show you some video when we come back
and stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
how are you on this Thursday
pumped up you ready to go for the
weekend
kicking names and taking ass
I think that's what we're gonna do
this next week
I'm very confident and what is going to
happen on Tuesday now I'm also very
confident that
after the election is done on Tuesday I
don't believe we're gonna we're gonna be
able to just stop talking about the
election
um we're gonna we're gonna have to
continue this conversation
on and on and on because these [ __ ]
they're not just gonna they're not just
gonna be like yeah we won
I mean they're not gonna be like yeah we
lost and concede they're not gonna do
that they're gonna say we won we won we
were cheated it was stolen
and I mean they've been prepping this
narrative through these polls that the
media has released Gabe Sanchez don't
you believe that these polls are
[ __ ] and this is all part of their
plan to deny this election don't you
agree with that yeah you should 100 not
believe the polls you should right but
you don't you believe that the
Republicans have kind of set this
narrative up and they've really worked
these right-wing polls into the
aggregate to really give it a little bit
hey we were look we were supposed to win
by 10 points and we lost about 10 right
like right yeah they're gonna I mean
they're gonna use whatever they can
denying [ __ ] they're going to use
whatever they can to dismiss the fact
that they are behind in any way right
they're going to be you know trying to
project false sense of security they're
going to uh use it as a tactic to
intimidate or hinder other people from
actually going to the polls to vote
right they want to use it as a means of
like because I've I've seen a lot of
people in my comments and things like
that that really come in with like a
defeatist
uh attitude right like well Democrats
didn't do anything so why would I vote
for them again
and it's like yeah it's uh it's almost
like they're watching like tyt or David
Pac-Man or some [ __ ] like that who
believed the polls they're like look at
the polls and it's you don't have to
believe the Bulls yeah and it really I
think that's the really you know to uh
you know Peter Griffin you know what
really grinds my gears
uh is the fact that when people look at
it and they're like what's the point of
voting right what's what's the point of
me actually voting if I know that it's
not going to change anything right
but we have to remember
that voting is an incredibly powerful
tool right
a powerful tool that we have
that Republicans are afraid of right
there are more of us than there are of
them and so they're using everything
that they can in their in in their just
toolbox they've got voter suppression
they're they're discounting votes in
Pennsylvania that don't have the
postmark date on the on the actual
voting sheet and it seems like the judge
the judges ruled in favor of that I
believe right yeah and so now they are
whole they're not throwing them away
they're just segregating
uh the the actual ballots that have a
postmark date on that they that they've
written a date on there versus the ones
that don't which is like I guess we are
just gonna dismiss the fact that a
government agency the United States
Postal Service actually postmarked the
envelope and said great it was sent by
this date right you would assume that if
a ballot was sent in this envelope
I would infer that any date prior to
this date is when they did it right
there it's not invalid it just means
that you made something that people
don't remember or don't realize they
need to look at the last sheet or at the
very end or whatever it is maybe if you
wanted to do that put it up front put in
a different position make it easier
however the people that are the ones
that are deciding how these ballots are
actually created or how they're written
are the ones who are intentionally
trying to manipulate the end results so
yeah we've got what's going on in
Pennsylvania we've got the things that
are happening in uh in Arizona I just
read last night about how Georgians can
report other people that they find
suspicious
to question mayor validity as a voter
which is just insane right like if
Georgia didn't already have enough
problems now we're calling in a question
let me let me tattle on this other
person who is just voting
and it's just it sounds like the same
stuff with like the clean elections USA
that we've been reporting about for for
weeks now we've been talking about this
clean Q Anon elect excuse me clean
elections USA out in Arizona where the
the federal judge says no you can't you
can't [ __ ] beat carrying rifles and
intimidating people you obviously have
intent and the judge said you're not
allowed to be near that [ __ ] drop box
with your rifles and your tactical gear
because you don't need rifles and
tactical gear to watch with your eyes a
box which is your right right and again
it's you know I I think I I shared
something about the like breaking news
that night and somebody wrote the only
reason they need to intimidate people
like literally set it out light they're
like the only reason they need to
intimidate people are for the or like
the only reason they need to intimidate
are the people that are stuffing the
ballot boxes
okay one you admitted that they're
intimidating and two you think that
people are just stuffing ballot boxes
well because again you have to a
widespread conspiracy to commit voter
fraud would mean that you would need
Millions right of people spread across
the U.S because if you had one District
that had like 400 500 percent voters
were just dumping ballots in there you
would be getting oh well I just
dismissed these this is this is insane
but you would need to be doubling up in
different counties in different states
in different regions of the country it
is a coordinated effort that I don't
even think George Soros could pull off
well here's the thing like in Arizona
because this clean election USA the one
single morsel of of truth because that's
what these [ __ ] boneheads do they
take one simple fact and they create
this entire [ __ ] story and [ __ ]
surrounding that one simple fact right
in Arizona there was a few ladies who
pled guilty to dropping ballots in a box
right that that were not legal for them
to drop in one of these boxes now if you
want if you look at the federal judge's
order the restraining order they say in
the order you have to put this language
on your website that it is legal to drop
someone else's ballot in a [ __ ]
Dropbox it a family member someone that
you're the the guardian of yeah someone
who lives in your home you can legally
drop those now these women that they're
that they're using these court cases
um these cases that they were they pled
guilty
these women did not know they did not
know that you could not take someone
else's ballot that's not your family
member and drop these in these boxes
right now that doesn't that still does
not negate that they did that thing
right so they had to plead guilty to it
the craziest part is they're taking what
is what is what is criminal guilty pleas
for four ballots four ballots and
they're creating this entire narrative
for the entire State as if millions of
people are dropping millions of ballots
the other thing too that's crazy to me
is in states where they actually get
mail-in ballots or absentee ballots
there are some states that automatically
mail you one right right which I I
actually think is the way we need to get
to uh faster like we need to get more
States on board with just mailing you
your [ __ ] ballot like I get my bell
in the mail right and the reason why is
because you register with the county
election office at your address yeah and
they'll mail you one ballot to your
address now when they do that I believe
that a person should use that ballot to
vote rather you mail that [ __ ]
from your unsecured mailbox on the side
of your house whether you decide to
drive it to a Dropbox that is secure or
you hold on to it and you take it to the
pole with you to vote and you may lose
it so you may have to do a provisional
Ballot or whatever the case
but this is more effective and secure
way and the reason why we know this is
because the 2020 pandemic right we
actually know that this is a more secure
way to vote just because the 2020
pandemic because they actually put more
scrutiny in more court cases over that
election than any election ever
and it was the most secure election
because it was the most scrutinized and
it had the most mail-in ballots
ever and I think that's what we're
really seeing
um now with this election with the early
vote do you do you do you think that
um it's this defeatism that we've been
talking about the last couple weeks
because we really been pounding on this
that stop being a defeatist you're
you're [ __ ] being a really whiny
little snowflake right um you know even
if we are losing you're making us lose
even more by right being a defeatist but
we're not but we're not losing these
early voting numbers are clearly showing
that people are are
um showing up to vote or making sure
their vote is cast yeah I I think 100
like we've got these people we talked
about you know tyt and David packman I
think that they're you know
as good as they are on you know having a
network and Outreach and and in total
their content's beautiful I mean it's
like I mean like yeah and they've got
they've got far far reach of people that
they can get to and and spread what you
know news let's go the other insane
things that are going on
however
if I had an if I had a network or if I
had the reach that they had right in the
audience
why would I tell people
well it looks like we're not going to
win the polls are not in our favor like
you're all you're you're setting up your
yourself for failure by again even if we
are losing in different areas right even
if we are not going to win a seat here
or there whatever it might be
you have to wonder
what's the point of you even
commentating on the news or what's going
on if you're going to be like well
so this is the deal guys I really think
that we're going to lose because these
numbers aren't that aren't that great
right but or or these polls indicate
this or that and here's the thing
polling is inherently flawed there are
many problems with polling we've talked
about it you know there are a lot of
things that current methods aren't you
know contributing for the other thing
yeah no go well I watched a great video
today on on Instagram and I wish I would
have saved it I lost it and I surely
I'll find it back somewhere yeah but it
was a young it was a young college woman
she was talking about how like the
reason why polls suck is because they
can't call me and mask the number as Mom
on my phone right and and and even if
they were able to show up on my caller
ID as Mom on my phone to pull me they
would have to text me 20 minutes later
and say hey why haven't you called me
back right look these young people do
not do not do the whole phone thing that
is not how they do it these these polls
are Antiquated uh I want to I want to go
to real quick before we finish up this
thought fake game here says early voting
numbers hmm he says where are they
counting votes they're not counting
votes dummy they're counting the amount
of ballots you [ __ ] bonehead I mean
really honestly this is this is why this
is why you people like fake gay believe
stupid [ __ ] so easily because you just
are completely mind [ __ ] you can't you
literally do not understand that there
is there is several ways to count things
like as ballots come in they can
actually count how many are actually
being mailed in before they actually go
through and tabulate the boat you dumb
[ __ ] no one is tabulating votes
idiot all they're doing is counting the
amount of ballots that are being mailed
in they have to they have to get them
like they have to they grab them you
know and they they put them in Secure
boxes to make sure they get when they
start counting them right there's a
whole there's a barcode envelope there's
a whole thing it's the same it's the
same with this [ __ ] guy I mean
Pennsylvania is another place right I
brought a Pennsylvania earlier but if
you remember Pennsylvania during the
election right there was the whole thing
of we can't count these mail-in ballots
until we've counted these in-person
ballots right like there's a whole thing
and that's why I was like what happened
it was like 3 A.M dropping it's because
all of these other [ __ ] ballots that
were mailed in were held off to count
the in real time person ballots because
Republicans pass stupid laws to do
stupid [ __ ] right then and so then
you've got this other situation where
they say well we're not gonna actually
acknowledge that
so how can you
okay so so here's the thing um
here's the thing fake Gabe see in a lot
of states you have to register as under
a party right now we don't know exactly
who's winning we won't know until
they're they're the votes are counted
but once they're counted we will know I
mean you guys will deny it and you'll be
in the comments next week but Democrats
didn't win it was stolen here's the
evidence de Souza is going to do another
movie or some [ __ ] like that
um but here's the thing here's the thing
here's a here's the thing fake Gabe they
know a lot of [ __ ] about your vote they
know it you register to vote you dumb
[ __ ] you may know where you live
do you remember when you got your
driver's license you remember when you
went to the DMV whoa whoa whoa whoa are
you about to educate me on how simple
things work I'm just saying you go to
the DMV yeah you get your driver's
license and they say hey would you like
to register like there's a whole process
would you like to add your registration
card to this address so we know where to
contact you in the future this sounds
like this sounds like the government
knows a ton of [ __ ] about me or
something it's almost like they've
connected two things so that they know
exactly where you need to go to vote
like when I first moved to to La I had
you know uh I had to go to my polling
station uh but I wasn't registered in La
yet so I had to do a provisional ballot
right and then the next because we had a
local election and then the next 2020
election that we had I was registered to
vote at that polling station right uh
and luckily mine is not too far from
where I live uh but at the end of the
day these are things that they already
know they have you registered if you're
not registered at the right address you
show up and they say oh you're not
registered here but we'll do a
provisional ballot which again is held
off you vote they segregate that ballot
and you you can it does not get counted
immediately they make sure that that
provisional ballot is valid before they
counted see fake game I I think I know
what he's saying here he's saying how do
we know who wins because the media's
report the fight news is report in it
but here's the thing Gabe fake Gabe
is that the Secretary of State's office
the election the election officers who
run the elections are looking at what
ballots they are receiving and they're
actually sending the numbers to quote
the media to show them how many ballots
are being cast it's not some [ __ ]
weird-ass thing it really isn't weird
it's not weird
it's not weird that we have election
offices that are run by people and they
know things and and and what they're
illegally able to [ __ ] send data to
they can't send it and I don't know how
many um this morning I didn't check it
I've been checking it but I'm sure we're
almost up to I'm sure we're almost up to
um 30 million uh votes cast which I
think is a huge uh record uh in a
midterm really honestly I I think
um we're probably gonna break mail-in
and early voting records even for 2020
with the right with the pandemic even I
mean he wants he wants the swords hey
hey hey fake game go look at any state
Secretary of State office and and what
they're reporting
that go look at what they're reporting
because that's where the [ __ ] numbers
are coming from you dumb [ __ ] also come
if you're from the election offices also
if you somehow doubt anything we've said
you can easily validate those you can go
to google.com
if you've got something that says that
provisional ballots aren't held aside
mail-in ballots aren't held aside
they're not counting if you can prove
any of these things to be false that
we've said please bring it up I would
love to somehow will easily prove you
wrong by just using just by just looking
at the link title there's a permalink
that's that's the URL you know in there
you're gonna have phrases like uh
provisional ballots not counted with
other ballots mail-in ballots held off
you know these are things that you don't
even have to read the article to
understand but also just common [ __ ]
knowledge and if you don't know now you
know so you have no links he says dude
but that's the but that's the thing here
is that you can go to a government
website right yeah you can go to a
government or you can go to the official
website of the state Elections office
that of any state that you want you can
go there you can call them you can go
look at the data that they're reporting
to the media so the media can report on
this so we know how many [ __ ] how
many how many uh early ballots have been
have been cast already this is really
stupid stuff that you don't know that
that that that who is collecting you
don't even know who's collecting the
ballots is [ __ ] just beyond stupidity
here it's just ridiculous caretaker 909
it is like we have to spoon feed fake
game with these rebuttals literally have
to slow it down so he understands we
should like down like I had to go all
the way in to explain how the DMV
registration Works to know that that's
how they get most of their information
about you where you live how you
register if how long how long do you
have to stand still for the picture
because that's what I've always wanted
to like look you got to stand sometimes
you look surprised like oh [ __ ] now
you're taking the picture sometimes they
won't give you a heads up they'll be
like stand here smile and they get you
and then other times they say okay uh
three two one go
um
who the person is and how nice they are
so now that we've educated you on how
you even get your picture for your
license maybe that will help you out
through this process being a flunked out
of preschool listen I actually don't
believe that
um that it is
uneducation that has brought fate Gabe
to his delusion I actually believe it is
his ignorance of how things even work
and his his pre-disposal to making sure
that the how he believes things work
work the way how he believes it
regardless of what the truth is as long
as it makes fake gate feel really good
about himself and about his beliefs that
he wants to hold so dearly as long as
whatever he believes makes him feel
comfortable right that snowflake will
[ __ ] believe it
regardless of how simple it is to use
rational thought to underpin everything
he's talking about like oh where where
are you getting the numbers of early
votes I don't know people mailing the
[ __ ] in what do you what do you
want from me what do you want from me
they're mailing them in they're dropping
them at drop boxes these people are
early voting fake Gabe what do you want
what the [ __ ] do you want it's all
voting I mean there's also uh just the
fact that like so we had we had
obviously mail-in votes everyone you
know was more kind of open to mailing in
their ballots uh during the 2020
election because of the pandemic
and turns out people are like oh they
actually this is way more convenient I
just put in the mail and it's done right
I don't show up especially for people
well there was a lot of things we
realized during the pandemic didn't we
right that's why that's why we have this
show like how we can do this show we
realized that through the band it's like
oh look companies can work from home you
don't have to be in an office nine to
five unless your Twitter no right
exactly nope and they're gonna move
everyone to Texas oh oh God it's it's
just getting dumber and dumber we won't
go too much into Twitter today but yeah
yeah uh though tomorrow it's you know 3
700 or so jobs that are tentatively
planned to be fired [ __ ] capitalism
bro right well you know you know Elon
Elon is going to be great for jobs at
Twitter I just know he's gonna be here
he's a job Creator that's what he is
Gabe he's a job
created okay uh Ashley says here about
fake games she says 4chan chode I want
she's asking the question Ashley this is
an actual valid question I talked about
this the other day this is how this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] gets [ __ ] just puked up
over and over and over again
from Tucker Carlson's mouth to fake
Gabe's little chat here that he's always
in the chat room
okay I experience this in real time and
had to explain it to one of these dumb
[ __ ] in real time in real life
not over a chat room like fake Gabe so
here's the thing
the Paul Pelosi attack all the [ __ ]
lines that were spread about it I went
to help a friend move some furniture he
was moving into his new house
and I had to help them move furniture he
had one of his buddies there to help
and his buddy is Maga right and he can
still lift things you know he can't use
his brain but he can use his arms and
his legs so he was good at moving
furniture but he just didn't have a hand
on the grasping reality
because as we're moving furniture he
talks about how Paul Pelosi's attacker
was naked and Paul Pelosi was naked and
they may have been having sex with each
other and I'm like okay first off none
of that is true I said you're none of
that is true I said the guy wasn't naked
I said Paul Pelosi wasn't as a nerd
because he was [ __ ] in bed sleeping
what are you sleeping so immediately
he's like oh okay well maybe that's not
not but 10 minutes later not but 10
minutes later he was kind of joking
around we were moving a piece of
furniture into the living room and I
said oh this goes underneath the TV he
said yeah where he's going to watch Fox
News all day and I was like oh that's
funny and he's like well he's like I
have to admit I really don't watch Fox
News and I'm like you know that's funny
that you don't watch Fox News yeah I
said but you do when you don't know it
he said what do you mean I said you
watch Fox News you just don't know it he
said how is that even possible I said
not but 10 minutes ago
not but 10 minutes ago you were telling
me about all kinds of nonsense that Fox
News has been puking up over the last 24
hours since Paul Pelosi got his [ __ ]
head bashed in by a hammer by a [ __ ]
manga assassin right I said and you're
puking it up right here in front of me
you don't know it but you're watching
Fox News dummy right you're
disseminating because Fox News says it
that's how information works that's how
it [ __ ] works they talk about it then
Gabe Gabe goes in this chat room and
this Facebook Q Anon group and they talk
about it and then they spread this Meme
and then all of a sudden you're having a
conversation with something hey man you
hear Paul Pelosi was having gay sex with
a socialist nudist and they were
sticking hammers where you know where
and then the cops showed up and that's
when they got vile I don't know what the
[ __ ] they were talking about all lies I
mean also just outright lines I think
the thing that I find uh totally on
brand for republicans and and hilarious
and sad at the same time is
when all this happened they're like all
right he's a gay leftist nudist from the
Castro right and I lived in San
Francisco and I happened to be in San
Francisco at the time so I woke up and I
was like by the way there's nothing
wrong with a gay nudist yeah there was
nothing wrong I don't know whatever
whatever floats your boat right whatever
it is
Republicans they're like look it can't
be this guy or he couldn't have attacked
him because he's a Castro nudist blah
blah all the stuff it's like okay
uh that's a light choice and a lifestyle
and let me tell you there's a lot of
Libertarians and a lot of conservatives
in in SF who also do those things and
are fine with that because that's who
they are right but it doesn't mean that
just because you are those things that
you immediately left us right
well I I do want to disclose Gabe if
someone broke into my house in the
middle of the night they would think I
was a nudist because unlikely I would
not be wearing any I I like to be
comfortable when I'm sleeping so I mean
I'm not trying to divulge it's too much
first I mean I know a lot of personal
information has been divulged about me
but I don't want to get two in the weeds
but God forbid Tony you sleep in your
own home yep in whatever way makes you
feel comfortable does that make me a
nudist I don't know I don't know I mean
does that mean because I know I'm I know
I'm a a commie socialist George
member of the antiva cabal but I don't
know of me sleeping nude every once in a
while makes me a nudist or not yeah I
don't know I'm not sure what the
qualifications are for that club I do
know I do have my antifa membership card
but I don't have my uh I don't know if I
don't know that's a good question I'm
not really sure I mean look like I said
I lived in San Francisco and I've seen
all the different parades and all the
different parts of this life did you go
to the nudist
um well if you go to if you go to the
Folsom Street Fair or you go to the
pride parade like you also the rules are
you you cannot derobe and become nude in
out in the public but if you were to
walk because it's indecent right right
but if you walk outside with shoes and
socks on and nothing else you're
completely fine that's how it works in
SF no joke wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait I
just want to be clear for all for
especially for fake Gabe because I know
he's gonna lose his [ __ ] mind here
when he finds out that you can walk
around with just a pair of socks on in
San Francisco ah the world's coming to
an end so you're telling me
that if you have a pair of socks and
flip-flops on which is classy by the way
to have socks on with flip-flops it's
kind of a Midwest trashy thing but that
is a thing you're telling me that you
can walk outside your home and just you
know free to the world that is how it
works I've gone to cafes and there's
somebody literally sitting down
nude and they're like reading their
paper no joke like there's a there's a
couple what a sight to see right I know
there's a couple like restaurants and
like breakfast spots that I would go to
with friends you know and like you sit
around just people walking around no
it's it's there's also a nudist beach
crazy NSF that's uh you know I used to
have been to a nude beach but here's you
know I've heard about it here's another
little detail I used to on my birthday
it's just like something to do I would
run into the ocean nude naked
so you are a nudist
that's all it takes I I'm I'm looking it
up right now on Google to be no I can't
tell you there was one year there was
one year I I ran into the ocean and
there was a couple so where the where
the nudist beach is it's Baker Beach
that's that's uh it's not too far from
the Golden Gate Bridge right so it's on
the Pacific Ocean Side before you get
into the bay right and on that side
there's a gold Gate Bridge and there's
Baker Beach and as you go closer down to
the Rocks where the bridge is that's
where the nudist Parts is right so
that's where Baker beaches
now there was a couple taking what I
believe was their engagement photos oh
yeah because it is a nice like
perspective yeah like you got a good
background right I've got I've got the
ocean I've got the sand I've got the
Rocks I've got this photographer's dream
however uh they decided to go to the
baker beach side that was the nudist
side right so that's where I did it
because that's what was allowed right I
went there so there are photos somewhere
that exist online uh-oh or uh-oh or
exist from this couple or the
photographer if he actually used them
where there are uh there is a person
running running behind running behind
them to go into the ocean uh and this
person may or may not be gay changes and
so because of that I believe that makes
me a I guess a leftist nudist but only
one I think that proves that you are a
nudist like but maybe that's going back
to this David yeah sorry sir uh this
David de page uh uh right wing
conspiracy theorist like here thing
again even last Friday so you know six
days ago we were on the show we were
doing we were talking about what was
going on you know it was kind of
breaking news and what we said was this
guy is not what's going I even called it
I was like look I've lived in San
Francisco and I can tell you for a fact
that people who do these things or live
this lifestyle or whatever
can be more than just a leftist right
you can you can [ __ ] around and do
whatever you want
and be a crazy right conspiracy
conservative whatever you want to be and
it turns out this guy was and as it was
happening in real time we were literally
fact checking and there were people in
the chat it was like that's not true all
this [ __ ] right
and then you find out
that within you know within hours within
days you'll find out more and more
details okay so he came and he attacked
him he wasn't naked uh Paul Pelosi was
in his whatever he was in right
nightwear his nightwear because he was
in his bed living there then we find out
more where somebody were where they say
oh well he's it goes from he's a leftist
uh attacker to he's now an illegal alien
and now they've moved over to well we
just want to see the body cam footage
right you got Tucker Carlson who's like
it's perfectly fine to ask questions you
guys are the Liars we're not crazy like
literally he's like we're not crazy you
are the Liars we just want to see the
body cam footage nothing's wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with asking
questions and if there is then we live
in a totalitarian state right but
you've got a doj document right because
this guy is obviously charged who's
facing up to what 50 years or something
like that well I mean that well he's
he's going to have several different
charges because even this morning
there's news that um because he he was a
Visa card holder from Canada and he
overstate his legal visa and they're
turning this into oh he's an illegal
alien like how don't you people know
that the majority of people who are here
illegally in this country are overstayed
decent how do you not know that right
like this isn't complicated so when you
when you've got these people like Tucker
cross and other people in the right wing
who are like oh well all we want to see
is the body cam footage which is like
one we're like all right great we've got
uh Capital police footage from Nancy
Pelosi's house that shows the break-in
we've also got confession a confession
from the attacker who is like well I
mean not only that he's [ __ ] social
media feed right it's full of this and
so as soon as as soon as this comes up
the first argument that people have is
capital police footage well this is so
[ __ ] made up he she doesn't live in
DC
I think they said that somewhere about
our title because on our title I I said
the other day I was like caught on
camera yeah yeah
caught on camera by Capital police that
was our title the other day yesterday
uh yesterday yeah yeah yesterday yeah
and so it's funny because all these
[ __ ] out there like oh what she
doesn't live in DC he wasn't a DC it was
an SF do you not realize that there are
security cameras around these people who
are sitting [ __ ] members of Congress
they don't understand Capital police is
the protection agency that protects
right Congress people that are I don't
know do business at um the capital but
the reason that nobody was watching it
is because she wasn't home so they had
real no reason to look at the food
because they're like look if she's not
home then there's no real threat
obviously there is because now your
loved ones are the ones who are under
attack right well because we have this
we have this uh the Republicans stoking
stochastic terrorism and even Dr
Gardner's like what is it is stochastic
terrorism real you're literally that you
are literally you're a terrorist in this
moment you are right right well let's do
this because we're at the top of the
hour yeah let's do let's go to the
shitless Roundup because I got some
videos I want to show you Gabe um since
you weren't here yesterday I know you
were building it so let's just let's
let's surf the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends why they still are a thing
start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up
on the Tony Michaels podcast Gabe I've
got a message from the owner of Twitter
here let's see what he has to say
hi
I'm
ma uh
money money
give to you
I I have no idea what this is I I
supposedly it's his doppelganger that
lives in China and Elon says
you know because this is what's
important in life uh he goes I want to
meet this guy assuming it's not a deep
fake who knows I don't know it looks
pretty close and I'm like I don't know
it could be a deep I I don't want to
spend too much time on the Twitter thing
but I know you've got some friends
um who are uh actually personally
affected by this right by this uh
absolute ditching of of Twitter because
he's driving it straight into the ditch
here oh right into the ditch I mean like
yeah it's so it is it is funny to watch
the knee-jerk reaction that a lot of
people are having who are like the Elon
stands and simps and trumpers and all
that [ __ ] who are like yeah [ __ ]
free speech capitalism I can tell you
from first well second hand because I
don't work at Twitter but I do have
people who work at Twitter and I've got
other friends who know other friends who
work at Twitter and I have uh friends
who used to work at Twitter who still
have friends who work at Twitter so I it
sounds like you work at Twitter it would
very much seem like I work at Twitter so
I sent out I was up late last night and
I saw Elon had tweeted something dumb
about [ __ ] bi-directional networks
and the amount of traffic that happens
on on Twitter and he was like oh uh
Twitter has bi-directional conversations
and it very much Maps a neural network
like a brain right
and I commented and I said uh you know
you you bought Elon Musk bought Twitter
with no real plan on how to generate
Revenue
because he didn't actually want to buy
it I mean right he didn't want to buy it
right it's like people are forgetting
the fact that gag that he he tried to
back out of this deal as as late as like
the end of July right well I mean even
Thursday before when he went into the
office before he went in when he was
threatening to fire all the employees
that was still him desperately trying to
get the shareholders to be like we don't
want this guy right right and since he's
joined this is what has happened he has
uh coming he's made unilateral business
decisions you know some small but
obviously some are larger uh like hey I
want to charge you twenty dollars okay
I'm gonna have a back and forth spat or
really it wasn't back and forth it was
just him responding to Stephen King
who's saying [ __ ] that [ __ ] you should
like a silent auction almost yeah he was
like okay okay look look what about
eight dollars what about eight dollars
how about that right if you do any of
you have children out there and they're
like look I just want this much money
like no I'm not giving it but what about
this much money like it feels like that
it really like he's haggling himself
down right he's like okay if not 20 then
let's do uh uh let's do eight dollars
right and okay you know what this is
what we'll do so here's the thing like
you've got that's the dumbest idea
because here I'll tell you why right
you've got all right you've got 237
million active daily active users right
and for people who don't know daily
active users uh I I don't know every
every company will will Define daily
active users differently but for the
most part it's someone who at least logs
in once a day right uh there is ninety
percent of the people who are on Twitter
lurk this is literally how it breaks
down for any social network you've got
90 who lurk they just like peruse they
have an account they don't they have an
account they don't do anything they just
look they just look maybe just reading
the news or right or following like
their favorite celebrity or some [ __ ]
exactly because after a certain point
you have to uh if you scroll enough then
it says hey you want to sign up or log
in then you've got nine percent the nine
percent of people so 90 lurk nine
percent are somewhat active liking
retweeting commenting occasionally here
and there whatever then you at the one
percent the one percent are people who
are tweeting every single day multiple
times a day liking retweeting commenting
sending DMS sharing it out and attacking
the one percent we the one the one
percent uh this is like the only time
I'll ever end up yeah this is probably
honestly it will be the only time and
we're probably not even the top one
percent of the one percent but we're
part of the one percent well we've got
some friends though that tweet the [ __ ]
out of the machine oh I bet Mayo one of
my favorite accounts Mayo I bet she is
oh she's like she is like I don't point
zero one percent like you've got to be
wearing out that that touch screen like
It's gotta be just worn out with just
characters and so you've got him trying
to say hey I'll charge everyone eight
bucks to verify right there are other
ways in which you can combat trolls and
Bots instead of charging them eight
dollars right you're you're asking and
then yesterday right which is funny
because I I find that you you watch him
on Twitter and he's throwing out these
ideas of like well this is how we're
gonna generate
he's getting real-time feedback which is
like yeah that's one way to uh to get
feedback on something you know in a in a
very effective way really quickly right
it's like you're not even a b testing
you're like should I even make this
thing you know what you know what you
would do I you know what I would do like
if I if I over spend money on a on a
social media property like like Twitter
yeah what I would probably do is make
sure that um I would have like a CEO and
some other people maybe uh maybe like an
entire staff that knew what they were
doing yeah at that said social media I
would probably make sure to have them
um I don't know I'm just saying it might
have been a good idea to like ask them
what they thought about some of these
ideas instead of crowdsourcing it on a I
don't know a platform where the only
people who really sent to you are
[ __ ] in cells that have no clue what
the [ __ ] they're talking about right
Bitcoin dudes I mean what is this [ __ ]
it's I know I look because right now if
you want to combat the trolls and the
Bots fine there's other more effective
ways that I believe you can however
if you're going to charge people to do
it eight bucks 20 bucks whatever you
want there are so many [ __ ] verified
accounts now that are literally going on
and being like you can [ __ ] have the
blue check mark man I don't [ __ ] care
of that right like I I worked I worked
my way to this position to to uh create
myself of notoriety rights whatever but
but but there's something more
underlying here and I I really I I know
you could talk about Twitter for like
six hours but here's here's what I want
to say most of the blue check marks
weren't even those blue check marks
didn't go try to get that blue check
mark Twitter gave them that blue check
right like they they gave it to them
right so it wasn't even like the person
was like you know oh I want a blue check
they gave it to him to make sure that
that was that verified account because
they knew certain celebrities certain
people are going to be imitated like
they automatic if you're running for
office they give you a [ __ ] verified
check mark right like that they give it
to you you don't have to like go through
the process and prove all this stuff
because they know if you've running for
office you've already proved who you are
to run for office to be on a ballot like
so they give you the blue check
it's so dumb it's a big mess and the way
I'll wrap it up here is like
he doesn't know what he's doing he fired
the board he fired execs he's no not
Elon he doesn't know what he's doing
come on fire he will tomorrow
tentatively planning to Fire 3 700
people and here's the [ __ ] thing that
pisses off me off the mulch so yesterday
I sent this tweet out right and I knew I
[ __ ] knew as soon as I sent that
tweet last night or early this morning I
was gonna wake up and I was gonna get a
ton of [ __ ] hate and I've got so much
hate from all the Elon stands and all of
them all the [ __ ] idiots because what
they're doing right now is they're like
Elon Musk is the most successful man on
the planet in history right they're like
he's so smart he's a genius yeah uh and
then you've got people I saw fake Gabe
like well then how do you want Twitter
to make money there are other ways that
you can make money Twitter was already
making money it may not have been the
most profitable and it may not have been
the way that you want them to or
whatever but they were already making
money and and yesterday yesterday the
other news before we before we wrapped
the Twitter because I want to get to
this Brazilian Nazi rally
um where they're trying to take over the
government because they lost an election
sounds familiar but um they use the
military by the way
um kind of has this Q Anon sent to it
yeah but here's the thing is that
yesterday we found out that one of the
biggest ad agencies in the entire
country that uh represents like Coke
Disney there's a lot of different big
organization corporations at this Ad
Agency represents that buys uh ad spots
on Twitter like I think it's probably
one of the biggest buyers of that
inventory on Twitter they basically said
no we're not going to buy Twitter right
now because we don't know what the [ __ ]
he's doing like that's what people don't
understand about Elon right now the
reason why he's a dumb [ __ ] is
because he's saying all this stuff that
isn't gonna be things yeah and it's
confusing a lot of people who spend a
lot of money because P capitalists
people who spend money on on their
business want to make sure they get
their return on investment and if they
don't know what this motherfucker's
doing or what he's going to do to
Twitter they're not going to spend money
there it's not because they can't make
money it's because they have no idea
what this [ __ ] idiot's doing they
have no clue they have no confidence in
him and frankly I think that's going to
be the end of the story and I want you
to comment on this and then we'll go to
the Brazilian store is what the [ __ ] is
going to happen with to the confidence
that he's the CEO of SpaceX and Tesla
because they're publicly traded
companies they have have boards and he
cannot fire the boards over there right
well SpaceX SpaceX isn't public oh okay
yeah yeah but let's talk about Tesla so
what I think is going to happen is
because what we're seeing well but
SpaceX is kind of bubble good Trader
because they only exist because of
actual government contracts right
exactly and the same thing with starlink
and right right you know but go go with
the Tesla right so what do you think
he's gonna I think what's gonna happen
is you'll you know what you're seeing at
Twitter is basically he's running people
down right he's making them work 12 to
14 hour days and anyone who tries to
justify an 84 hour work week because
they're literally working seven days a
week right now to get [ __ ] done for
these uh unilateral business decisions
and random arbitrary deadlines to verify
and and charge people money
if you're okay with that you got
something [ __ ] wrong with you okay
because I've seen a lot of that [ __ ] in
my comments anyway the way that he
treats employees
at Twitter is the same way he treats
them at Tesla and SpaceX and all those
things but when you start focusing a
hundred percent of your your energy on
the thing on the new shiny new toy that
you just bought because you're trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] exactly to do
with it because you're like I don't know
how to make money and advertisers are
pulling out and you're losing money
right the only thing that's saving you
is uh Jack Dorsey rolling over his
shares for about a billion dollars right
that actually helps Twitter right jack
dorsey's keeping in afloat and by the
way dumping all the employees off your
payroll is also keeping in the flute
right exactly and so you know job
Creator but what's going to happen I
believe and I said it early on like I
was like I don't you know I don't think
elon's gonna buy this because I think
what's gonna happen is he's gonna put
himself in a very uh he's gonna over
leverage himself in terms of trying to
buy Twitter but also being who gave him
too much credit you gave him too much
and and so I gave him too much credit
maybe and so what I think will happen is
right now the board is going to begin
assessing seen what he can actually do
because Q4 he's going to fire people
he's going to show he did great and he
owned owned the [ __ ] lambs and did
all this stuff and all the right-wing
people are going to say that's how
capitalism works right but I think I
know quarter one though what's going on
quarter one I think it's gonna it's
gonna [ __ ] the bed by the end of Q2
you're really gonna see the [ __ ] hit the
fan but I think what's gonna happen with
Tesla is and SpaceX too but also
specifically Tesla because you have
publicly traded company with
shareholders the board
is going to look at this and be like uh
you you can't you can't do three or four
companies you cannot do this you cannot
own this company and try to run it
because you don't know what's going on
you you will have to either hire someone
right to run this company for you
because you have now distracted yourself
you're talking about Twitter
specifically yeah yeah I think I think I
think Tesla will be like look here's the
ultimatum you either assign someone else
to be the CEO and deal with that you can
own it but the day-to-day operations you
got to figure that [ __ ] out with
somebody else right because if you don't
you're gonna keep distracting yourself
flying driving to all these different
spots that you need to be at to get
Tesla running or to keep Tesla running
and we are going to be up in our most
competitive moment here in the next few
years as other car companies like GM
being yeah specifically they're already
I mean in China they're already like
hitting them with that like it's you
know they're pulling advertising they're
they're doing this they're they're you
know revving up EVS in terms of
alternatives to Tesla because Ford's
been hot on their tail but uh like Texas
Paul said the other day these these
vehicles that GM has are some of the
most competitive electric vehicles that
are going to hit the market
um that that have ever hit the market
right and and not only that you're now
you're going to have the foreign
manufacturers that are here building
cars uh Honda Toyota they're dumping
they're dumping tons of their lines to
now to now compete and Elon
I honestly I think the only way Tesla
survives is if they [ __ ] dump Elon
because they're not they're not going
they're not going to compete on a level
that they need to compete because their
autonomy is now in question the market
really is the market of the electric car
is no longer about autonomy now that the
United States government in the
infrastructure bill has said we are
committed to making sure we have
infrastructure for electric vehicles
right like that they have they have made
that commitment which means that the
auto manufacturers here in this country
rather they're American companies or
their foreign companies that have
factories here are going to start
dumping their lines I think Toyota
dropped Avalon
um I believe I believe Honda is going to
drop some of their bigger sedans
um to actually start producing EVS on
lines here in this country because they
want to be competitive because GM is
leaning all the way into it they they do
not give a [ __ ] they're going to lean
all the way into this and and what it's
going to do and I don't know if people
out there don't understand what
capitalism is they're they're going to
Edge Tesla out and Tesla as a board and
shareholders are not going to be happy
if Elon is distracted by Twitter and
getting edged out of the market for EVS
because that's what Tesla does so I I
agree with you I I think I think elon's
and
um his is up to his neck and his ego and
really honestly he got himself into
trouble here I actually gave him too
much credit I thought he would actually
pay the fine he would walk from the
Twitter deal I really thought I gave him
way too much credit I thought he was
smart enough to know that he was not
going to be able to make Twitter a thing
and he would walk away just take his
loss and just never mention it ever
again I really gave him too much credit
I think I think we both yeah yeah and so
and I think what we're going to see now
is the board I I don't know how many
voting rights he has on the board and
whatnot but I definitely do think that
the board is will you know considering
the potential loss of their brand and
their mascot which is Elon Musk and how
they're competing in the market I think
it will be one of those moments where
the board says look you're either out or
and you can focus on if you want to
focus on Twitter do it all yeah but you
can't do it here well but but I think I
think maybe you're giving the board too
much credit because I'm not saying that
Tesla won't won't tank because yeah yeah
I mean they could like he could
literally take it like based on again I
don't know what the voting rights are on
the board that he has or what his family
member has you know obviously they're
going to vote with him but it's one of
those things it's like does hubris take
down these companies right and Twitter
Elon Musk is SpaceX because he's lost a
ton of wealth a ton of wealth I want to
move to this Brazilian story this this
video is
man it really
um it's something else now we know that
Lula won in Brazil now he's if if you
were to
um kind of compare it to our country it
would be like Donald Trump losing in our
country right
um the the the the current president who
is a fascist uh was defeated by Lula who
is uh kind of a populist and some call
on the Socialist he's definitely to the
left he's definitely for democracy and
not fascism
and this scene erupts outside of
military installation
um these are
um how do you say bolsonaro is that any
say his name
um they they're outside the military
installation here because they don't
believe they lost and they want the
military to intervene this really sounds
familiar
um it seems like we went through this a
couple years ago where people were
deluded that that they hadn't actually
done the thing to do and then they
wanted the military to intervene they're
going to sing the national anthem here
and they have the Brazilian flag but
watch the salute
do you see the salute their game do you
see the one uh this is um you see now I
I definitely
okay that's uh that's a Nazi salute oh
you know
I have to say
I was watching a documentary
um on
Adolf Eichmann you know Adolf Eichmann
is
Enoch Eichmann is the Nazi that was
captured in South America
um after he escaped Europe once
um he was able to get to South America
because he was a Nazi and he was part of
the concentration camp in ashwoods he
was part of the the the the the part of
the SS and the Nazis who were excited
about Exterminating entire race of
people
he went to Brazil and they found him and
they brought him to Israel and the
Israelis actually tried Adolf Eichmann
it's a huge you can go watch the the
documentary it's it's um
it's actually kind of frightening uh in
the time that we're in but the crazy
part is is that they sent the Nazis to
South America and here we have Brazilian
Nazis this is something else this is
really something else now again this
seems like a lot of people this is what
these people do they they get up a bunch
of people to make the entire population
very terrified that they see how many
people they got there yeah look at them
all man they're just they're [ __ ]
excited about this Nazi salute
geez it's something else isn't it it's
something else yeah um now I mean
obviously they're in the minority but
right it is definitely still scary to
see this I mean we obviously we see
those things all the time that are
supporting Republican party they're in
Florida they're in Ohio they're in
California you know all these people who
are anti-semitic bigoted races
homophobic transloc all these people who
think you know the that white is right
and keep round down and all these things
that they say in terms of their little
chance that they do with their [ __ ]
little dick energy
it is the minority they are in the
minority they are screaming
screaming Kicking and Screaming as the
minority because what they are are
afraid and we you know we said I said it
earlier is like voting is a powerful
tool and if and and the one thing that
you know if is true
is that if your vote didn't matter if
your vote was like ah whatever really
didn't matter
Republicans wouldn't spend all of their
effort trying to gerrymander districts
and spend hundreds of millions of
dollars trying to suppress your Vote or
trying to fight in the courts that say
that oh you know we shouldn't count this
ballot for XYZ dumb reason
so that's how you know Republicans are
threatened by anything that is
pro-democracy
so when you see stuff like this remember
they're in the minority it is still
scary and it is still dangerous because
obviously a minority can grow and they
can build up and if you give them oxygen
then they can then they can they can
grow larger obviously on the show we
shine a light on it because we want to
let you know that this [ __ ] happens we
want you to let you know that it's not
just a one-off thing there's a bunch of
these things happening but in order to
stop them we have to literally call that
[ __ ] out when we see it right and and
here's a here's an example of that this
is oh yeah yeah this is in Tulsa
um this is a donut shop I guess they had
I guess they had a a drag show here and
this this snowflake gone for a bit a
private business had something in their
own establishments right and capitalism
had someone show up in a in dress up and
sing and dance and P this person this
snowflake that you're going to see is
very highly offended because Tucker
Carlson told him to be but watch and
Matt Walsh well watch what uh happens
here in this in the scene this is a news
report from channel six it looks like
surveillance video from the donut hole
catches a person and dark clothing and a
red hat walking up to the business
around 2 30 this morning I just want to
say that is a great name for a donut
shop and then the donut hole that's I'm
just saying I kind of I kind of want a
donut now that just the name alone makes
me hungry yeah for donuts really I mean
donut I remember going to Dunkin Donuts
I think it's just called Duncan now but
getting donut holes and bringing it to
class on your birthday dude you you
would be the the most popular kid at
school if you brought you know Donuts
that's a great name for it the donut
hole but watch what this [ __ ] this
guy in a red hat
um does investigators say the person
first puts a letter with anti-lb gtq
rhetoric on the door of a neighboring
business then uses a bat to smash the
glass door once it's broken you can see
the person light a Molotov cocktail
throw it inside and take off it's got
you know you know chemical of some kind
in it uh that is meant to spread fire
quickly
when I first watched this the first time
this this fire chief here he's he's
smiling like he's kind of I was like why
does he look like he's I feel like I
know why right yeah because I'm like he
he really feels like this is funny and
I'm like this isn't funny but watch
watch why he thinks it's funny this is
this is great and cause a great
potential of damage it's also
firefighters say the homemade explosive
did not spread and only caused minor
damage inside surveillance video from so
so the guy in the red hat the domestic
terrorists can you can you go back to it
yeah yeah just keep talking but go back
to the part where he's talking he's
giving the interview yeah so here's the
thing is that
the guy throwing the molotov cocktail
into the donut hole is dumber than a box
of donuts yeah like literally it's you
can't make this [ __ ] up what what are
you looking for so I uh I heard about it
I did not see this video and definitely
didn't watch the interview pause it
right here yeah so here's the thing one
is the guy what I find funny too is the
guy goes up uh and tries to smash
whatever window or door was there goes
once it clearly doesn't break he tries
it again it clearly doesn't happen so he
like shifts over and he goes to the next
one right and he breaks the window but
the reason I I knew everything was okay
in terms of this business was because if
you look behind it all of that inside is
totally fine everything is perfectly
okay and the person is walking in to set
up or move things outside he's actually
moving like a child's high chair yeah
right exactly but you look at it and
you're like oh look it looks like
there's chairs inside the walls aren't
charred there's no fire because the
whoever [ __ ] threw that in there they
committed a crime uh because they were
triggered by a private business right
and you know in the world of capitalism
a private business decided to do
something in their own property see this
is where it starts people it's not
hyperbole This Is Where It Starts hey
you want to point this out Gabe you see
this is a this is a Corona Extra 40.
this is a 40 ounce did he he bought I
don't now I don't know I mean obviously
it's an empty bottle but this guy he
went all I don't know if he bought this
specifically to drink it and then do
that I don't know but that's kind of
yeah it's I you know what I wouldn't I
kind of would laugh if this idiot was
like yeah I just gotta buy this bottle
of Corona Extra and put a rag in it and
then light the rag with gas oh my [ __ ]
so you're saying maybe maybe I think I
think yeah alcohol the alcohol the beer
would I think also sometimes bottles are
really hard to break and that's an
example of the bottle not breaking right
you know it's like the guy the guy
because the point is is it's supposed to
break and spread right and that's I
think with the fire cheese like why he's
laughing he's like you know technically
you're supposed to because that's why
he's used a lot in riots because they
toss it way up in the air and then when
it comes down it breaks on the street
yeah and and it spreads the chemicals
that are on fire and it hits the people
who in the crowd where they're throwing
it but I think this is twofold I think
this idiot didn't use the right
chemicals or really thought I could just
light this beer on fire and then two was
he can't throw it hard enough that it
would actually break so it just kind of
like sat on the floor and then that was
it you know you know what I bet this guy
also doesn't know I bet he also doesn't
know that when mail-in balance are come
in that they actually count how many
ballots are coming in wow they don't
actually tally the vote but I bet he
doesn't know that he I bet he doesn't
yeah I know I I probably doesn't know
that he probably doesn't know how to use
a multi cocktail and he probably doesn't
know how like just simple like voting
works yeah probably but you look at you
look at this and you're like this idiot
came to this place to commit a hate
crime against a company who did
something privately and so what I want
to say is this is how it starts okay
this is great this is I'm not hyperbole
there's no hyperbole here this is how it
starts
you have people who are very triggered
right again the very few but some of
those very few people are in higher
power switch means they can rule and
dictate things like taking away women's
rights and certain you know rolling back
voting rights and all these other things
but this is how it starts you got people
who are upset that a private company did
their own [ __ ] thing in their own
business they weren't hurting anyone
legal stuff legal totally legal stuff
they decided to play music they can
dance they can sing they they were
committing no crime they were doing what
they want to do and this is where it
Tran this is where it translates from a
private business doing their own thing
to I want to I want to come into your
home into your private home and I want
to I want to conduct a watch to see what
you're doing in the bedroom and I would
almost bet I would almost bet the same
um the same dumber than a box of donuts
again yeah this red hat this red hat um
non-fire thrower yeah you didn't know
how it works I would almost bet he was
really pissed off that a private
business could tell him to put a mask on
I'm just saying and I wonder where he
got it from here is um Tucker Carlson on
White Privilege tonight on Fox News news
let's let's listen so here we are less
than a week before the Democratic party
is expected to suffer overwhelming
losses in the midterminal see do you do
you see why they've been they've been
making sure that the polls have false
false data built into them so they could
say this let's keep going elections and
here you have the leader of that party
Joe Biden commanding you not to complain
about the election results
hey
I don't think that's what Joe Biden said
at all I actually think a lot of people
are going to complain because
complaining complaining is one thing
you're like people complain that that
that Donald Trump you know even though
he lost the popular vote he won the
Electoral College vote and so people
complain because it is your right to
complain you you could be in the total
wrong about complaining right you could
be a total Karen and say I want to see
the manager I want to see the man you
know I'm gonna Sue all of the machines
every machine out there I want to sue
your cash register I think the amount
and the total is wrong sir let's let's
keep going here let's see what he let's
see what he says about the the dictorial
um complaining that that Joe Biden
talked about
why is that why is it well let's see
here's Joe Biden telling you that thanks
to the changes the many changes
Democrats have made to our system of
voting all of which make voter fraud
easier to commit we may not know the
results of the elections for a few days
but don't be alarmed everything is
completely on the level and whatever you
do do not ask questions or else you're a
criminal
hey fake Gabe it
um I just want to make sure that you
listen to this so that way you can put
it in the chat here in a minute I want
to make sure you heard you want to play
what Tucker said again so that you can
put it down in the chat yeah that way
you can copy what he said you can say
the stupid ass [ __ ] lies that he had
listen never in the history of our
country have they closed the polls in
that moment and been like uh votes
counted votes accounted polls are closed
votes are counted it takes a little bit
to count the [ __ ] it actually
does and the funny part is is fake Gabe
was alluding to this earlier and he's
probably right now seething typing in
what Tucker just said which is going to
totally be the opposite of what he was
telling us earlier I'm almost sure of it
oh yeah and almost sure of it because
that's what these dumb [ __ ] do
they can't pick a lane Dumber they're
dumber than boxes of donuts they really
are yeah they they honestly look at this
and they're like wait no well it's
my narrative it's dude pick a lane and
commit to it because you're either going
to say it is this or it isn't this and
then as soon as you're proven wrong well
I never said that that's this it's no
you're just dumb dude like all of these
all these people like fake Gabe who come
in here and want to spew these things
don't understand how a democracy Works
don't understand the fact hey we've got
millions of ballots that were mailed in
that we did not count until after the
in-person voting so yeah it might take a
minute because now we have to open that
[ __ ] up it's in an envelope now we have
to open the envelope we have to unfold
the thing right we have to literally
scan it through the machine we have to
do like
did does does fake Gabe think or anyone
else think that if you don't increase
this other external factor that it's not
gonna cause a little bit of a bottleneck
because you have all of this back
loading you have to do I mean Democrats
Democrats really honestly I'm all for if
those ballots are mailed in and and they
can actually they can actually tell that
those ballots are valid I think they
should they could they should start
counting and they should segregate that
count as what that count is it's really
easy to tabulate account and then say
hey we gonna set this count aside that
way if there's any provisional balance
that we need to double check we can do
that before we actually make this the
official total they can do that kind of
stuff it really is not hard to use logic
ranchers
it is hard to use logic maybe rational
brain thinking I don't I don't want
people to think that we are our
intentional I'm intentionally picking on
veggie but I want to say that it's more
of about him being the Trump copy
machine here's another example of this
and fake Gabe if you would drop the link
and
drop the link in the chat where there
were fentanyl uh hidden in bags of
Skittles for Halloween the serfs have
this here they said super awesome this
dominated news cycle rather than talking
about climate change wage theft
systematic inequality structure
institution racism disproportionate
incarceration rates oppression of trans
people worker workers striking
Corporation corporate inflation and
stagnant wages here's the top story zero
zero that's how many kids reported got
rainbow fentanyl quote unquote and trick
or treat candy after meteor film
fear-mongering here's the thing all that
was complete [ __ ] [ __ ] just like
we were saying on the show that's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's all nonsense it
was all it was all right-wing push to
get the [ __ ] media to say this [ __ ]
to scare you and to scare [ __ ] people
and it's not even a thing it's not real
it's not real fake Gabe it's not real
it's [ __ ] fake it's just a [ __ ]
mind [ __ ] you and control you on other
issues like I don't know bail What
machines and ballot boxes bad like you
really you really need to pluck it out
and [ __ ] understand that they're
manipulating you and here's a perfect
example of that so I want to tell the
service thank you for uh pointing this
out because again I don't think we
should hide from this stuff I don't
think we should hide from the fact that
the media bought this stupid right-wing
story Hook Line Sinker where brown
people were bringing rainbow fentanyl
across the border and they were somehow
gonna buy houses on blocks to pass out
these drugs to white children I have no
idea how this even [ __ ] in a
socialist country you've got people that
aren't from this country that come over
and give you drugs for free right and I
guess that is social somehow
either infiltrating the the Skittles
parent company or or opening the bags
and putting I'm not sure I don't know I
don't know like I don't understand the
logic on that one but let me tell you
what they're trying to distract you from
here here it is because this is I I told
the audience yesterday on Gabe and I
believe this this is the race they want
to win they want to win Kerry Lakes Race
there they've given up on odds they've
given up on Walker they've given up on
some of these Governor's Races they
definitely gave up on JD vancer about to
give up on Ron Johnson they want this
carry late governorship they want it bad
and the reason why is because with the
governorship and an executive uh the
executive power in Arizona they can
really really really really [ __ ] around
with this goddamn fake election [ __ ]
yeah and this deep this this fake ass
fraud story about how they're there was
election fraud in 2020 and it's going to
be really interesting to watch this but
listen
listen to what this bonehead's saying
this is what they're distracting you
from fake Gabe you want to know who's
going to take away your vote buddy do
you want to know here it is but you
cannot let the 2020 election with all
that went wrong go untouched and sweep
it under the rug because when I'm in
office it's coming back out from under
the rug we're going to examine every bit
of that and we're gonna fix it she's
telling you out loud that she is going
to overturn the election the LA not not
the one like that they're now going to
have they're gonna go back another one
how many more are they going to go back
and negate your vote you dumb
[ __ ] they're distracting you
they're distracting you get you to for
vote for people who are actually going
to take away your vote you dumb son of a
[ __ ] yeah that is what they're doing I
mean the people that the people that
watch this in regurgitate don't
understand that you know we said it
before which is like first you take away
rights from women then you take away
rights from people of color you know and
the the white dude's like yeah let's
yeah it doesn't affect me these aren't
things that affect my life and then soon
within a short amount of time you know
you've got this white dude looking
around and being like wait wait wait
hold on wait I used to have these rights
and they're like we don't [ __ ] care
wait wait why are you taking away my
guns Republicans well because you'll use
them on us you're you're violent so
we're gonna take away our world we're
the government that's taking away the
guns that you feel right that you need
the guns to protect yourself from right
okay so here you posted this video and
this goes directly what we're talking
about here from a tick tocker and the
quote this is the easiest this guy that
Alabama Nick is the easiest
easiest most simplified way to look at
this whole thing right and you can go
follow them on Tick Tock Alabama Nick
official I think it's his handle uh yes
it is Alabama Nick official just just
type that in all one word and Tick Tock
and you can find him Alabama Nick
official but you you pulled a quote from
this video he says in the video and
we're gonna play it here our vote is the
most powerful tool we have in a
democracy use it wisely protect your
family I love this messaging here
because he does such a great job of
breaking down why it is so important
that you value your vote fake game okay
um you also say here vote blue to
protect your family from the party that
wants to oppress it because that's the
truth and listen to what
Alabama Nick says here
how can I simplify this
if my brother is gay
if my sister is transgender
if my daughter deserves bodily autonomy
if my cousin is a disabled veteran it's
about my family
I would do anything to protect my family
if you are affiliated with a party
legislation policy action to oppress my
family
you're not going to get my vote our vote
is the most powerful tool we have in a
democracy
use it wisely
protect your family
[Music]
so go follow Emma Alabama Nick official
on Tic Tac because this is not just a
one-off he's got a great way of of
putting this information into 60 seconds
in less than 60 seconds to give it so
you can share it because that's the
point here that's what I that's why we
keep saying engage and lean into your
democracy that's why we show these
videos because we want you to share them
we want you to share them with your
family I want to show it to all the fake
games out there because I pick on big
game but he's not just the only Trump
copy machine they need to see this stuff
they really need to see how their brains
are not operating correctly on on this
thought process
um another video I want to go to do
um where did it go
well let's let's talk about the cash
Patel because we're we got about 15
minutes left here oh yeah
cash uh I'm uh I'm uh I'm a snitch Patel
yes absolutely well I mean here's the
thing is
um dude got put into a room with a bunch
of prosecutors he also put this on
himself okay this is this is this is
most likely a result of him going on to
Fox News and saying I was there when
Trump was declassifying these documents
admitting out in public
all like buzz I was like I was there in
December January when Trump was trying
to decide you know where he was waving
his hands yeah like we were in this room
with boxes
he was the one who said it and we all
joked you know but also seriously like
hey uh you might want to get a lawyer
because there's a [ __ ] subpoena
coming your way
uh and uh it turns out that they got him
here is Cash Patel this is now they're
crediting here as real America's voice
contributor
it's on a Trader News Network here this
is hours after he has taken a deal with
the FBI and the doj just hours after he
has taken you gotta love it this is not
a plea deal people have to understand
this is a limited use immunity deal what
that means is the doj has hard evidence
that he committed crime
and that he is now going to be immune
from part of that crime by giving his
testimony they will not be able to
charge him for that crime because he's
going to trade his testimony now the the
federal government does not give limited
use immunity that often yeah they do not
give it the only time they give it is
when they have a really good suspicion
that the person they're giving it to has
they have hard evidence that they
committed crimes and that they're going
to trade the immunity for those crimes
for what they think is testimony that
will actually result in the conviction
the the indictment and the conviction of
other people with way higher crimes but
listen this is just hours after cash
Patel does this deal with the doj Nampa
listen one doj and FBI across the board
to eliminate this two-tier system of
justice that they have created you must
must investigate and seize the
appropriate funding from these
institutions until they comply with the
law
whoosh so the guy who and what's crazy
about this really honestly is he's just
gaslighting he's just gaslighting the
viewers yeah on on real America's voice
he doesn't actually believe this [ __ ] he
does none of this what he's trying to do
is tell all the cultists that watch this
show the thing that they want to hear so
they get distracted by him getting
limited use immunity where he's going to
[ __ ] he's going to testify against
Trump because he's testifying in the
hear me he's testifying in the documents
case where the doj the FBI and a federal
judge gave a search warrant based on
three criminal statutes three criminal
possible uh crimes against these
statutes to go get documents at
Mar-A-Lago
Trump's [ __ ] home in his desk drawer
in his office on the floor in his wife's
underwear drawer this is serious [ __ ]
[ __ ] and this is a sign that yes the doj
is moving on him like a [ __ ] they are
gonna grab him by the [ __ ] documents
and they're gonna swing him around like
he's never been swung before that's why
he was mad last week when the sealed
meeting didn't go his [ __ ] way and he
freaked out on true social and that is
why cash Patel listen to me
that's why cash Patel is doing this
limited use immunity deal because cash
Patel is not going to be immune from all
crime right this isn't like a pardon
what this is is limited use on certain
crimes that they have hard evidence on
that's what it is so good luck to cash
Patel but more than anything
good luck good luck to his to his boss
it is Paul made this uh cash video is
about to become a coffee boy it looks
like
um oh wow yep I mean it really is that I
mean you also have to remember the the
memes that were that was sharing I'm
trying to find if cash is on
uh untruth social to see what he's
saying over there I'm sure he is because
him and Devin Nunes are good butt
buddies and I want to go to the Cheeto
dust q and honor because I think it's
important uh today there's news where
he's gonna file a lawsuit in Florida
against the New York attorney this
doesn't make oh yeah yeah I I was just
reading about that yeah so yeah um so
here's what speaking of true social and
fraudulent post over there the Cheeto
dust Q anoner types in today I filed a
lawsuit and Florida State circuit court
against the corrupt Attorney General of
New York State
he's got that wrong a state of but
anyways uh letitius peek-a-boo in quotes
this I that's is that a racist thing I
don't know I mean like when we talked
about it somebody said that somebody
said they found something on it I'm
pretty sure it sounds racist right it
sounds right letitious peek-a-boo James
I wanna I wanna know what that means
before I say that but boy it really
um sounds
um like it could be New York state is
one of the most crime ridden places on
Earth with murders robberies drug deals
and every other form of crime setting
records on a weekly basis not true
um while James does nothing to protect
New York which she is filing many cases
honest on a regular basis so are
prosecutors all around the state under
the attorney general and the state's
Authority against violent crimes and
criminals she attacks great and
upstanding businesses okay there
fraudster and then
down below he says which have done
nothing wrong projection will like the
very successful job in tax producing
Trump organization that I have
painstakingly built over a long period
of years he's admitting admitting right
on fraud social that he he and he alone
is painstakingly built the [ __ ] Trump
organization that is in a criminal trial
right now this is you cannot make this
[ __ ] up this would ruin any other
[ __ ] out there ever you would no
one would even send you a nickel after
you would admit this out in the open
he goes on to say crooked and highly
partisan James now thinks it is the
business of the state of New York he
finally got the state of New Yorker
correct here to go after my revocable
trust and pry into my private estate
plan when you commit crime that's what
they get to do only to look for ways to
recklessly injure me my family my
businesses and my my tens of millions of
supporters how in the [ __ ] is she
banging up his supporters what no no
good job of doing that himself his
business is his family he literally uh
oh my God so what I was reading earlier
was that
um
I guess Donald Trump uh in in response
to
uh
uh cash Patel you know obviously he's
like oh [ __ ] you know this is really
things coming after me I guess they were
a round of appearances he made on
right-wing outlets and he started and
this morning actually so this is like
all still happening but I guess he said
that he wanted uh Mitch McConnell to be
impeached and that he claimed the
Republican members of Congress had
something on him it was some kind of
radio show you know he phones because he
can't get his makeup on that early in
the morning he's like yeah he said in
Peach Mitch McConnell I don't know if he
knows what impeach is or who
right and I don't know if he knows that
uh what the executive branch judici I
don't know if he knows who has the
[ __ ] impeachment I know he's he's a
bonehead
um but yeah he's saying some crazy [ __ ]
because well it's all it's all kind of
crazy because even yesterday we saw
during the The Oath Keepers trial that
Trump had penned but he never sent
uh a letter to Stuart Rhodes
who again is under uh you know he's
under trial for seditious conspiracy
fake Gabe and Jeremy Johnson crimes
against the United States of America
relation to the January 6 Insurrection
so there's all these things like [ __ ] is
hitting the fan from all directions
right you've got uh Georgia and you've
got Lindsey Graham having to testify
you've got uh the you can't uh you know
wanting to keep certain things sealed
for you know Trump uh
the nothing seems to be going his way
Ash Patel also is Elena habakash Patel's
lawyer I see them together often I don't
know if they're actually you mean she's
representing him and Trump at the same
time that's what I'm that's what I'm
wondering I see them together and I
don't know if the reason they're seen
together or have been seen together is
because I just wanna I just want to go
on a limb here and say that's probably
not the truth and here's why yeah yeah
that's what I'm asking there's no way
Alina Haba has any [ __ ] idea how to
negotiate a limit limited use immunity
deal with the deal so [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way okay so yeah you could not
convince right well that's why that's
why I was like I wasn't sure but I've
seen them photograph together well right
occasion so I'm like what's going on
here because cash is with Trump yeah but
then I would also assume that you could
like if you've you could not represent
someone that is now potentially being
used against you in a court or in it in
a grand jury
um my guess is my guess is the reason
why all these early votes are happening
is is several different reasons one they
are really sick of these [ __ ]
criminals thinking that they can have
our government right and have their way
with it grab it by the documents as it
were
um so I think that's one reason but I
want to show you another reason here
yeah people are [ __ ] pissed off I
mean the road thing is is growing by the
[ __ ] moment I think they had no idea
how
how [ __ ] much this country would say
[ __ ] off when they overturned Roe v Wade
like they had no idea what the
ramifications were going to be with the
turnout yeah but here's the other one
that's starting to emerge uh because
Mike Lee was caught on tape saying
something that probably isn't what you
want to say and it's kind of weird in
this tape and I'll point it out but the
president of the United States
um Joe Biden said uh just the other day
that Republicans are going to try to
abolish Medicare and Social Security
which that's their plan but listen to
how Sean Hannity frames it up here you
know now in this last Stitch effort well
let's lie to this uh senior citizens and
scare them to death with lies about
Republicans they want to take away your
Social Security and Medicare and cut it
okay not a single Republican has ever
said it no Republican supports it
okay you hear you heard what Sean handy
said Sean Hannity said no Republican and
I I apologize for the volume these
videos sometimes online are really low
but Sean Hannity says here that no
Republican has ever said ever in the
history of ever ever if there was ever
that they want to abolish
Social Security especially no sitting
Republican for crying out loud right
let's go to let's go to Mike Lee of Utah
He's a United States Senator Gabe he
would be voting on this let's listen
what's it it will be my objective to
phase out Social Security eyes
as he says it's a [ __ ] old people
it's so bizarre the people who are
literally the recipients of Social
Security Medicare like all of these
programs they earned it they [ __ ] they
[ __ ] earned it they earned it this is
not entitlements you you I don't know if
I I'm sure I have to explain this to
fake Gabe you don't know how [ __ ]
drop boxes and mail-in ballots work but
when you work in this country when you
work it doesn't matter if as long as you
fill out a certain tax form for when
you're trading your labor you will have
to pay you will have to pay into
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security it
is a thing that you pay for your
employer sometimes also pays for it if
you're self-employed they actually make
you pay more into it because you don't
have an employer that's paying into it
because you have to contribute to get it
or you have to be disabled to not be
able to work to get it it really is not
complicated to understand it's not an
entitlement it is something you [ __ ]
earn you earn it and here Mike Lee is
standing here acting uh well and I'll
show you I'll back it up look at these
older folks here they're not clapping
this guy's got his hands they're like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you're gonna take away our
social security like how the hell do you
want us to [ __ ] it's already so if if
you take I mean like you know let's for
people like they gave and Jeremy Johnson
in the chat and other [ __ ] Mega
people right the Trump copy machine if
you take away
Social Security
the thing that people oh my God okay the
thing that people get right so they're
not working they're retired they're
getting these checks and that's their
only source of income okay
what is your alternative the thing mind
you again that they paid into
all of the years that they were working
they paid into this program there's
government assistance that at the end of
their time you know when they retire and
get older that they say great
I've now earned this thing that I paid
for right I put into the pot
now who knows if this program will be
around when we retire right like this is
you know we're talking another 30 or so
years where do we even get this we'll
even be left for us who who [ __ ]
knows right but right now the people who
are receiving that Aid and that
assistance and that money
sitting senators and other people you
got Rick Scott as well who are saying
we're going to get rid of it we're not
going to have social security we're
going to cut Medicare cut Medicaid so
then what are those people gonna do if
they have no source of income how are
they supposed to pay for this [ __ ] on
the private Market
that's what I don't understand they they
make a problem or they fix a problem by
creating another even bigger [ __ ]
problem and then leave you high and dry
no money no health care and then they
say okay well good luck go find it I
don't know like you got someone else
that can pay for it like the person
loses their house they they lose any
source of stability in their in their
life that you know they're on the street
like it's a it's a very quick domino
effect if you begin removing things like
[ __ ] basic Healthcare from someone's
life and also the thing that helps pay
for the food and the groceries and the
other type of expenses in your life that
you need to pay for like I don't know
where you [ __ ] live so fake Gabe is
pointing out something here he's
pointing out something here and I want
to address it because I talked about
this yesterday you bonehead you were
here I talked about this he's here's
what he's talking about
the White House tweeted out how social
security has went up the cola the cost
of living as assessment went up on
Social Security which if you had the
Republicans wait they're gonna take away
your Social Security there's going to be
no Cola dummy but here's the thing
he's he's saying that I'm going I
ignored the fact that Twitter is owning
Biden because that oh the only reason
why Cola went up is because inflation
went up I talked about this yesterday
you dumb [ __ ] go back this is
this is the reason why Gabe you need to
go fake baby you need to go subscribe to
the YouTube channel okay and the reason
why is because you will go back to
yesterday you were here you were here
man you were here how many times how
many times I had to [ __ ] say
something freaking beat into your
goddamn brain I said yesterday that the
right wing is freaking out on Twitter
because they don't understand that when
inflation happens wages should inflate
the reason why so many people are
freaking out about inflation in this
country is because the problem isn't
inflation the problem is is that their
wages are not inflating you dumb
[ __ ] the corporations are taking
all your [ __ ] money fake Gabe and
they're not giving it back to you with
what you deserve in your labor so what
happens with Social Security because it
is earned by by when you work you get
assessments on cost of living increases
so as inflation Rises they do what they
should do increase and inflate your
[ __ ] wage that you traded for your
labor your entire life and you paid into
the system you are such a [ __ ]
bonehead you are such a dumb
[ __ ] and you are a trump copy
machine and frankly it really it really
really really disappoints me that I
mentioned I talked about this for like
10 minutes yesterday
where you were [ __ ] here man you were
here
I just don't get it I don't understand
it really honestly we probably never
will understand fake Gabe I mean it just
oh my God it's it's he's so easy though
to to school that's why we pick on it
don't stop don't stop yeah don't stop
fake Gabe can you can you can you send
us your photo yeah can you send us a
photo of yourself because a lot of
people keep asking in the chat if we can
make you bone ahead of the week I'll
make a special [ __ ] award great for
you because I don't take I don't know
yeah I don't want to take I don't want
to take away from the other participants
that are in the bonehead of the week but
I will make you your own award so if you
want to send us your photo with your
face on it I can cut it out and I can
put it on a little graphic for you that
way you can always cherish it sleep it
by your pillow it'll be great you know
frame it if you want you know bonehead
of the month kind of plaque you know
just send us your photo I don't have the
chat bonehead yeah
just send us your photo thank you with
your face
making it so easy for us it's so easy
it's so easy everybody same time same
place tomorrow tomorrow's Friday Gabe
you know what's on Friday in the second
hour bonehead of the week speaking
United of the week so everybody go make
sure to subscribe right here to YouTube
you can vote for bonehead of the week
here on YouTube also go over to Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod watch Twitter still
a thing you can vote over there
um as long as it's not ditched by
tonight uh there will be a poll for bone
net a week so you vote you decide to use
the bone of the week tomorrow and Friday
in the second hour of the Tony Michaels
podcast we will break down bone of the
week also download every single episode
on Apple Spotify Google fake game don't
forget to download yesterday's episode
where I talk about the thing that you
say I'm trying to ignore I talked about
it for like 10 minutes yesterday Go
download that episode fake Gabe go
download it [ __ ] re-listen to it you
were here I don't understand why you
don't know that also you can you can
watch on Facebook on the Midas touch
Facebook page unless your band fake game
then you have to come over my page at
the Tony Michaels and you can watch the
show there so follow us on Facebook as
well everybody same time same place
tomorrow
Surfside [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon